so then you were you were also on The
Drew Carey Show for seven years
yeah not nine years nine years yeah when
you were on that show did you think that
this is it this is what I'm gonna be
doing and then that's it or it didn't
feel that good when I was saying this is
it
walk on set one so we can go carry on
fire you know drew and I worked out that
if if read about season seven there if
it was pair word I was the highest-paid
actor in Hollywood because all I said
was getting a vibe that's the only thing
you say there's other dialogue you know
we were looking at it one week because
when you get into these show you still
doing that set comtesse nothing right so
when you when you get to like year seven
or eight you're pulling down some money
yeah and I one episode I had all I said
was Gary you're fired
I fight it wasn't even that it was an
episode where drew goes to China and
somebody tells me and I say China and
walk out that's it that's all I said I
said the word China and I got paid next
worth the one and it's a lot of money
yeah it's weird because they call me a
lot and they go hey we couldn't fit you
into the script because I'm like fifth
leader right but they pay you
yeah they go but so have fun yeah it's
literally like oh I just got a free
check for no reason that was exactly
like me that was weird yeah it doesn't
it's good cuz like who doesn't love the
money but it's bad because you feel kind
of weird right right yeah it feels like
oh they don't they don't want me they
don't want me or they don't need me and
also because I'm you know an alcoholic
right recovering alcoholic I have still
have that ISM and that like I just had
this narcissistic kind of self-serving
kind of mental think that do you think
that I mean I'm also a recovering
alcoholic you say but I have to say
but I think that we're not the only
people who suffer from narcissistic
self-serving impulses right I think that
you will find a lot of guys around the
Oaks gourmet
[Music]